هل يمكن أن تخبرني قليلاً
عما كان عليه الأمر مثل ما كنت
تسمعه إدوارد تيموثي
جيدًا ، كنت مثل سماع أصوات عالية ،
ما رأيك في أنها كانت عالية ،
ما كنت تعتقد أنها كانت
جيدة في البداية ، بدت
وكأنها شيء مثل  كانت تفرقع
مثل نوع من الألعاب النارية ،
لذا عندما سمعت أصوات نوع الألعاب النارية ،
كنت تعتقد أنها بعيدة
عنك أو قريبة منك ،
بدا الأمر كما لو أنني سمعت أنها تشبه إلى
حد ما بعيدًا ،
لكنني سمعتها مثل إدوارد تيموثي بصوت عالٍ حقًا
كان معلمك
معك عندما سمعت الأصوات
أه نعم حسنًا
في البداية جاءت سيدة
إلى الفصل وطرق
أبوابنا بقميص أرجواني وقالت
اذهب واختبئ وأطفأنا جميع
الأنوار وذهبنا إلى الخلف  من
الفصل ووضع المكتب
أمامنا وكنا مختبئين ،
هل تعلم عندما جاءت السيدة ذات
القميص الأرجواني هل تعلم لماذا
كان عليك إخفاء وإغلاق
الباب وإطفاء الأنوار
نعم علمت أننا كنا  هكتار  ving تمرينًا
حقيقيًا
لأننا تدربنا كثيرًا
وأعتقد
أننا نقول إننا آمنون لأننا نتدرب على
عدد المرات التي اضطررت فيها لممارسة
تمرين كهذا قبل
أن نبدأ في روضة الأطفال جيدًا ،
كيف نمت الليلة الماضية
جيدًا؟  كنت نائمًا مع أمي وأبي
مرة أخرى لأنني كنت خائفًا قليلاً ،
ما الذي تخافه الآن من إدوارد
تيموثي
حسنًا ، لديّ خوف من
أسلحة أم
الآن لأنني خائف من أن يقوم شخص ما بإطلاق النار
علي
العنبر عندما تسمع ابنك
يقول ذلك  عبرت لك من قبل
عن خوفه ،
لا لا ، هذه هي المرة الأولى التي أسمع فيها هذا
ما يشبه سماع
أنه يحطم قلبي ،
هل تعلم أن بعض الأطفال الآخرين
كهرمان
أم
لا ليس شخصيًا ،
أعلم أن هذا أمر عاطفي للغاية عليه
كسرت قلبك لسماع ابنك يقول إنه
كان خائفًا ،
نعم
العنبر ،
ماذا تريد أن يحدث ،
أنا فقط لا أريدني لأنه كان
يسألني هل يجب أن يذهب إلى المدرسة
العام المقبل
وأنا فقط لا أريد  عليه أن يخاف
من المدرسة أريده  استمر في
التعلم ولا تخاف
من العودة إلى المدرسة ،
نعم ،
يجب أن أعيش حياة طبيعية مرة أخرى ،
نعم